[Music]
on this busy Friday night a fourth new
coronavirus case in Canada the latest
patient the uncertainty for Canadian
residents in Wuhan we're not sure if we
will be able to get on the plane and the
facts on how to protect yourself
the UK's Independence Day the brexit
cheers and jeers what happens next
new stunning accusations against the
u.s. president as his impeachment trial
winds down plus the grocery giant
sacking plastic bags an Ottawa timeline
to ban single-use plastics we need
action
global national with Donna freezin
tonight Robin Gill good evening and
thank you for joining us we are tracking
a number of developing stories around
the world tonight from the impeachment
trial in Washington to the United
Kingdom formally and finally leaving the
European Union we'll take you to London
for our brexit coverage in just a moment
but we begin with the latest in the new
coronavirus outbreak canada has now
recorded its fourth case an Ontario
woman in her 20s who recently traveled
to China the outbreak has now killed 258
people in China around the world more
than 11,000 cases have been confirmed
most of them are in China but the number
of countries to detect the virus
continues to grow the United Kingdom
Sweden and Russia announced their first
cases today that makes 26 countries and
territories in the US where six cases
have been confirmed authorities are
taking aggressive steps they've declared
the outbreak a public health emergency
and starting Sunday the US will deny
entry to foreigners who have traveled to
China in the last two weeks they've also
imposed a mandatory quarantine on nearly
200 Americans who were flown back from
Wuhan we still have a low risk to the
American public but we want to keep it
at a low risk and because there are so
many unknowns here we're gonna take the
action in a temporary way to make sure
we mitigate as best as we possibly can
here at home health officials say the
risk to Canadians is also low they're
urging people to remain calm in
tonight's top story
Heather York's West takes a closer look
at the newest Canadian case we're here
today health officials say Canada's
fourth case of novel coronavirus has
already fully recovered the woman in her
20s from London Ontario had recently
traveled to Wuhan China but had so
little of the virus in her system
initial test results came back negative
the test on this individual was done a
week ago and at the time that was the
very best test it was the original test
that we had all been working on
actively after running samples through a
more sensitive test available only
within the last few days the results
changed and health officials don't
believe any other person has been put at
risk every time she had contact with
somebody in Canada she was wearing a
mask her disease parameters are quite
low and the system took all precautions
when she was in contact with the
hospital Canada may now have four
confirmed cases of the new corona virus
but the risk of infection remains low
that's not the case for those trapped in
the outbreaks epicenter bin Jang is a
Calgary resident who's now stranded with
his young family in Wuhan with two young
children we definitely want to be able
to go back to Canada they're more
vulnerable to their immune system is not
as strong as adults so we're definitely
more concerned for them Jang is hopeful
his family will be allowed to leave on a
Canadian government charter flight in
the coming days but their situation is
complicated their children are Canadian
citizens but he and his wife are
permanent residents if we are not
allowed then none of us are going
because I'm not sending a three-year-old
and a seven month old on a plane with
somebody else citizens of the UK France
and the United States have now returned
to their respective countries where they
are under a 14-day quarantine but
details about Canada's evacuation plan
are still not known we are engaged with
Chinese authorities around repatriating
Canadians who are in China and concerned
for their safety it is a deliberate
process in which we are engaged
responsibly and we will have more to say
on that in the coming days giving people
like the Jung's little else to do but
wait as this international health
emergency continues to play out around
them Heather your ex West Global News
Calgary there's still a lot scientists
don't know about the novel coronavirus
but here's what they can say about how
it spreads the corona virus is
transmitted from person to person
through water droplets created when an
infected person talks coughs or sneezes
just to give you a comparison take
measles that virus can travel up to 30
metres in the air making that disease
highly contagious but with the novel
coronavirus
must be within two meters of an infected
person and the water droplets must reach
deep into your lungs
scientists say you can absorb the
droplets through your mouth nose or eyes
you could even contract the virus if you
touch a contaminated surface than touch
your face but scientists say the risk of
transmission in that case is low and
proper precautions like regular
hand-washing can go a long way to stem
to spread well it's official brexit is
done after three long years of debate
and political back-and-forth Britain
finally broke away from the European
Union that is the official bell
signaling Britain's independence from
the EU right now thousands of brexit
supporters are celebrating in the
streets chanting and cheering in central
London it's a chapter in history meant
to unite Brits but as Redman Shannon
reports the divide is bigger than ever
before a very British farewell to
Brussels the brexit party's European
lawmakers getting ready to party back in
London things were already heating up
not exactly
magnanimous but this is a victory chorus
from voters sick and tired of delays
[Music]
the extreme ends of this poisonous
debate again drawn to Westminster stage
to display on this historic day
supporters of the losing side showed up
to what could have been a moment for all
sides to move on is not encouraging any
compromise for so many Britons brexit
Day is a celebration but effectively
it's a day of symbolism come Saturday
nothing will really change Britain's
future relationship with European Union
has still to be decided ganna be a piece
of cake
this transition agreement will be done
by the end of the ly shouldn t the Prime
Minister's own father confident his son
will again prove the doubters wrong
there's a big day I was a remainer but
but a nation voted in you know in 2016
we had this massive majority in 2019
there's no question the country ready to
leave here we go young Boris meanwhile
was far from home bringing his entire
cabinet north to probe Rex at Sunderland
physically and symbolically far removed
from all the hot air of London in
Boris's words he got brexit done but as
his predecessor Winston Churchill once
said this is not the end nor the
beginning of the end but it is perhaps
the end of the beginning
Bradburn so given all that's happened
what form will a future relationship
take well that is the big question Robin
but perhaps the question for tomorrow
right now tonight here in London people
are still hanging around Parliament
Square after the brexit deadline pass
where there was such a huge buzzing
electric atmosphere when that clock
ticked at 11 o clock tonight people
celebrating not really worrying about
that question for now but yes tomorrow
that self-imposed deadline but from the
UK government an 11 month window to
strike a free trade agreement with the
EU there potentially looking at an
agreement similar to the one that Canada
has with the EU but that's a very short
time frame Boris Johnson says he will
get that done
again and you can be sure that many
people who came here tonight believed
him Robin
Breton Shannon in London so many people
outside London were waiting for this
moment wanting Britain to go it alone
for years and lead the EU for good
our Europe bureau chief crystal
commencing spent time in England's north
this week to find out why they wanted
that and what they're looking for now
say ball tov is the focal point here
it's what's known as a calendar church
365 stairs in the tower 12 columns and
52 large windows but around here days
have been tallied waiting for brexit I
think we're rejecting globalization
definitely and don't think we're in
rejecting democracy because it only
benefits a tiny minority of people
people here in Boston voted
overwhelmingly in favor of brexit saying
they were tired of politicians far away
with no understanding of the community
telling them how to live their lives it
is a common complaint that we have heard
time and time again about isolation from
people across Europe in the United
States even in Canada with wex it first
of all I will ask the government to let
us have some more money so we can tackle
the issues with the infrastructure
global news first chatted with anton
danny a year ago back then he was a
counselor now as mayor he's struggling
with europe's open border policy when
you have 35,000 people jump into almost
80 you haven't got nothing to the
infrastructure is hit the biggest 10
people what they will do they will
resent the idea of migration because i
cannot see my doctors within two or
three hours i have to see him in three
weeks
armed with their EU passports Eastern
Europeans flocked to Boston skilled
workers who filled big gaps in
manufacturing and the agricultural
sectors now if they want to stay they'll
have to apply for residency I want to
stay here because
I have a contract I'm happy with this my
change is rough it's not gonna be as
clean as we think it's not it's not a
hot knife in the butter we're not gonna
go that's why you're up there gonna make
sure that we we we will have some
difficulties to leave Europe but that
doesn't matter to those who say they've
never felt any tangible benefit to 46
years of being in the EU we're no better
off now the working people in this
country than we were under Queen
Victoria we might have homes we might
have central heating and we might have
color televisions but we're not treated
any better and crystals back in the
London Bureau crystal the people you
spoke to are generally happy but do they
recognize how divided their nation is
over this issue absolutely and many of
them shared stories about spats between
friends and family and no surprise that
many were engaged in confrontations on
social media but now that brexit is
technically done although there is still
that transition period they say they are
hopeful about the future and they
actually use the word freedom saying
they at least have their sovereignty
back Robin crystal commencing in London
tonight the impeachment trial of u.s.
President Donald Trump is entering its
final stage the Republican majority in
the Senate blocked new witnesses from
appearing despite more explosive
accusations about the president's
conduct emerging just this afternoon our
Washington bureau chief Jackson prosecco
joins us now with more
Jackson let's begin with those
accusations well Robin there was another
damaging release from John Bolton's
forthcoming book bolt and of course he
is Trump's former national security
adviser in his book he alleges the
president directed him to pressure
Ukraine to dig up dirt on Joe Biden two
months before that now infamous call
between Trump and Ukraine's president in
the end though the Senate will vote on
Trump's fate and answer the question of
whether or not he abused his power
without hearing from additional
witnesses like Bolton but isn't this a
reason to proceed with more witnesses
well Democrats certainly argued that to
be the case and some of the moderate
Republicans felt that way too but most
felt it wouldn't accomplish anything
given the fact that Trump will
eventually be acquitted by the
Republican majority it would have taken
the votes of just four Republican
senators to pass the measure to call
witnesses but that simply didn't
materialize at the end of the day so
where do things go from here well
negotiations are now under way it seems
like this is all going to come to a
close early next week either just before
or just after the president delivers the
State of the Union address and right as
the 2020 election campaign heats up with
the Iowa caucuses Robyn Jackson Prosecco
in Washington a disappointing deja vu
for Canada's veterans coming up a Global
News exclusive on all the unspent money
meant for life after the military
tonight in a global news exclusive we've
uncovered a key document that shows
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau was trying
to get India to back Canada's bid for a
seat on the United Nations Security
Council it was one of the reasons for
his ill-fated trip to India in 2018 and
recently Canada has been attempting to
rekindle its relationship with the Asian
superpower our chief political
correspondent David akin has been
working on this investigation David for
nearly two years there has not been a
single ministerial level visit between
Canada and India a sure symptom of a
frozen government-to-government
relationship but that changed in
December when India's foreign minister s
Jaishankar became the first foreign
minister to meet the new Canadian
foreign minister Francois Philippe
champagne in Ottawa that meeting was
seen as significant by both sides in
fact many see champagnes appointment as
a signal that Canada will end a foreign
policy approach that some in the
international community found too
preachy too full of virtue signaling in
favor of a more pragmatic approach
Canadians and Canadian interests
including Canadian business interests
are better served when we are are seen
to be an ally and a partner and
thoughtful in our approach as opposed to
we're here to tell you how to live your
lives and while the
government-to-government relationship
was frozen the people-to-people
relationship has been improving India
represents the largest source of
immigration to Canada foreign students
have gone from 40,000 to 200,000 in a
five-year period no tourism to is up but
sticking points remain Global News has
learned that one of the objectives of
the ill-fated India trip had been to get
India to back canada's bid for a seat on
the UN Security Council that vote is
later this year that trip went
topsy-turvy beyond that though India is
cool to the Canadian bid because Canada
opposes the idea of India or anyone else
getting new permanent seats on the
Security Council and unless Canada
relents on that point it is unlikely
India will use its considerable
influence among other South Asian
countries to hell
the Trudeau government succeed at the UN
India's really sort of moving towards
and has been moving in the last couple
of decades towards what they consider
becoming a major power their foreign
policy is an extension of their
interests and so what memories of Justin
Trudeau's disastrous trip to India are
fading it seems an opportunity was lost
a window had opened and then just as
abruptly closed and it could be a decade
or more before another Canadian
politician has the same hope and
optimism about the Canada into your
relationship the Justin Trudeau had in
the winter of 2018
David akin Global News Ottawa Trudeau
was also under fire for breaking a
promise he made to veterans according to
documents obtained exclusively by Global
News
the Liberals allowed 105 million dollars
allocated for Veterans Affairs Canada to
go unspent in the 2018-2019 fiscal year
that money can be used next year in 2015
Trudeau slammed the Conservatives for
leaving a billion dollars unspent for
veterans and suggested that would never
happen under a Liberal government led by
him in total the Liberals have left four
hundred and seventy seven million
dollars budgeted for the department go
unspent since Trudeau took office and
for more information on the Liberals
lapped funding for veterans go to Global
News za / global national still ahead a
stadium in Russia now reduced to rubble
after a deadly disaster
you are watching global national the
serving video shows the moment a stadium
collapsed in Russia as a construction
worker is seen cutting through a beam on
the roof of the structure as the beam
gave way the Sports Complex caved in
around him demolition work had been
underway in preparation of a rebuild of
the Soviet era facility the worker did
not survive a Canadian billionaire is
shifting Aston Martin into the fast lane
as the British car maker looks to bounce
back from a huge drop in sales Laurence
troll who built his fortune in the
fashion world is now leading a
consortium that has agreed to buy up to
a 20% stake in Aston Martin stroll is
already a part owner of the Formula One
team racing point f1 he plans to rebrand
the team Aston Martin f1 under a 10-year
sponsorship deal that begins next year
for the first time the international
governing body for track and field is
admitting that recent developments in
running shoe technology may give runners
a performance advantage still world
athletics is allowing Nikes
controversial vapor ply shoe to be used
in elite competition the organization
wouldn't rule on whether its unique
design gives runners an unfair advantage
in the last 13 months athletes wearing
vapor flies have recorded the five
fastest marathon times ever pollution
solution up next so be says bring your
own bags but is Canada keeping up when
it comes to going green
the list of businesses banning
single-use plastics just got a little
longer today Sobeys has removed all
plastic grocery bags from checkouts at
their 255 stores across Canada the
second largest food retailer in this
country is now the first national
grocery chain to do this but what about
a federal plan here's my Clicquot to go
into a grocery store and you'll likely
find shoppers bring their own bags at
one major chain you'll have to do it
because they've removed all plastic bags
at the checkout it's a no-brainer for
Debbie Arnold we got to think of our
younger kids getting older in the
environment and making it safer for them
so I think it's great idea it comes as
the federal government announced it's on
track to ban certain single-use plastics
by next year Environment Canada's first
draft of an assessment of our plastic
pollution problem was released on
Thursday and it paints a grim picture
Canadians throw away more than 3 million
tons of plastic waste every year only 9%
of that is recycled globally plastic
pollution is a real problem the
equivalent of one garbage truckload of
plastic ends up in the world's oceans
each minute that's why the Environment
Minister applauds companies that are
banning plastics most companies are in
the same place that Canadians are which
is they feel like we're too slow they
feel like their governments are not
acting quickly enough federal officials
say after 60 days of consultation the
list of banned plastics should be in
place by the end of this year
environmentalists hope it'll result in a
pan Canadian plan to replace what they
call a piecemeal approach dozens of
municipalities across the country have
banned plastic bags but Prince Edward
Island is the only jurisdiction to do it
province-wide
we need action that mirrors the scale of
the problem and so bold commitments by
countries to eliminate these unnecessary
and problematic plastics greenpeace
points out it's been two years since the
United Nations deemed plastic pollution
a global crisis and they say Canada
needs to start being a leader on this
issue instead of
laggard Michael cooter global news
Ottawa and that is global national for
this Friday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is this snowy playground in Hope
Town Quebec we would love to see your
corner of this country so email your
pictures to viewers at global national
calm thank you for watching and I'll see
you back here tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]
[Applause]
you